how are you good at you you look amazing
can we get a pan on this look incredible
you performed earlier at the village
right how'd it go it was amazing it was
so much fun yeah you've had such an
incredible year your music is really
starting to take off what's been the
biggest pinch me moment for you this
year
this year probably the song going on the
top 20 at Radio that was probably the
most like insane thing but also fights
on getting over a million streams the
first day was really crazy yeah I know
that you're a good friend Justin
Bieber's married yeah did you know did
you have to keep that a secret uh yes
and no I mean I kind of don't really
like wanna but in service and then so I
I kind of I knew but I also wasn't like
running around being like guys I know
this big secret it was I don't know I
just kind of want them to like do the
thing and be happy is that hard for you
was a more of a blessing or a curse that
people know you so well because of
Justin Bieber and we're always asking
you about it I think it's both I mean
like I think he's amazing and he's such
a credible artist and he's helped me so
much in my career but I also feel like
it's amazing that I've been able to like
stand on my own two feet and just really
like flourish as an artist so I thank
him for all of his help and like pushing
me because no one believed in me sooner
than he did so
I'm getting raps but I want you if you
don't mind to dig in here and play a
little holiday Santa hat game there's
questions in there
what do you splurge on when it comes to
gifts I only flirt when I give gifts
other people like only who do use more
junk everyone that I'm friends with
literally but I don't know jewelry it's
my main thing that I go for usually
probably jewelry yeah my favorite gift
thank you so much
[Music]